scale single cell omics thanks very much
Laura thanks Adrian um thank you
everyone it's super emotional to be here
and so many amazing people and
um in such a great meeting uh literally
waiting two years for this moment so
thank you uh Sandrine and thank you
Roderick and
and Stephen and um
and everyone else who helped organize
the meeting
so um I have I'm the last person today
and I'll try to be on time I have 30
slides in three parts so and my main
point will come in slide 24. so
um and I'm gonna
um uh yeah I wanna be on the theme of
the of the meeting and talk about like
what we can learn from very large data
and in particular I want to talk about
one thing I learned and it it's a simple
thing but it's it's a basic thing and
it's it has to do with really the topic
that that's been recurring today which
is
um you know single cell data and
specifically how to normalize data and
why we use the negative binomial
distribution that's really what I want
to talk about
so I was motivated actually by two
papers that you know were
finished in some form during covet but
my lab had been working on for about
four years so the last four years and
one of them was
a paper on
isoform cell type specificity in the
mass primary motor cortex very related
to what we heard about in the first talk
this morning
um
this was an analysis performed primarily
by my student Cena was hogi as part of a
large
Consortium to study the mouse brain and
we this was a part we did there was
another project in my lab which had to
do with of all things you know
sequencing a single cell atlas of the
jellyfish and I'm not going to tell you
much about these projects just two
slides on each but they motivated lots
of questions that have
then become the the computational focus
of my lab and really something we've
devoted several years to now
so let me just say briefly about this
project and what questions have
motivated so this was I think fair to
say the first very large scale
uh detailed isoform level Atlas we first
put it out in 2020 and
um we analyzed I think around 38 billion
reads for this is large scale fair to
say I think
um and what we did in this paper is we
we looked at spatial data from a
technology called murphish smart seek
data along with 10x data which are
different kinds of single cell RNC data
they all measure transcription so
they're not really modalities like
Elizabeth just talked about because
they're all about just RNA and we didn't
integrate these data we we a point of
our paper is how we use the data sets
these of each other in conjunction to
try to assess
you know what isoforms are active in
which cell types and
and we we developed an atlas like this
um I want to say more about it today but
we had for you know the cell types that
were annotated in in this region of the
brain a very detailed resolution of
which isoforms
are present in one cell type and not
another or in the combinations of cell
types and what we did in this paper
primarily we searched for examples where
at the gene level there's no real effect
you see between cell types but there's
isoform switches underneath the hood and
we even identified cell types that you
might miss where you'd just look at a
gene level analysis you know in the sort
of smoothie or Lego analogy we saw a
great one earlier today of why you might
do single cell well this is why you
might do ice form analysis so there's a
lot of action under the hood but in
order to do all of this we needed to do
what many people do nowadays with single
cell which is normalize the data
dimensionally reduce and all that sort
of thing and we this was complicated
because we have different data types and
so question number one was you know
which data set should we use how would
we combine them and we didn't really
know so that led to lots of questions
and I'll just say that there's a whole
issue of nature this was part of a
project called the brain initiative cell
census Network and I think some dream
and several others in this room worked
on it as well
um there's lots of papers in this issue
all of them faced similar challenges and
performed what you might think was
fairly standard analysis and made
figures like this uh that many of you
have seen already both today and in
other talks
um I should say after working on this
for a few years we were uncomfortable
based on really digging into our own
little corner of this project with like
how all these steps are working
the same kind of feeling came about in
this jellyfish project I wouldn't say
why or how but I collaborated with two
great groups the Anderson lab and
Caltech and the Holliston lab in France
and for various reasons my lab you know
sequenced the first jellyfish Atlas but
the interesting thing is we did actually
an experiment and about four years ago
there were not actually many experiments
with single cell NEC you had people like
sequencing a tissue but not really
looking at different conditions and
Performing replicate experiments in each
condition but we did that in this
experiment we had five jellyfish that
were starved and five that were healthy
this is a jellyfish that at the time
almost nothing was known about it it had
a very a sort of genome sequence but
nobody knows what the genes are and so
our goal is to see which genes are
different in starved and fed animals and
to figure out at a single cell level
what all the cell types are in this
jellyfish there was not even another
single cell jellyfish out there
so for this project uh you know we did
that kind of thing and we had like a
picture of is this an animal we managed
to tether the cell types to parts of the
animal by doing in c2s and it was a lot
of work
um there's four close first authors uh
Tara was my student at the time as well
as Jess uh Gehring who's now across the
street at Arcadia biosciences but I
learned a lot as a more competitional
biologist about how hard it is to really
know for sure that something is maybe a
cell type and one of the interesting
things here because we had five
replicates in the fed and starved
animals
um we could ask questions about what's
the difference between them
State versus a type of self and and we
have figures in analysis about that and
I don't want to get into that except to
say that these are questions that emerge
from these two projects
um you know first of all as a first step
you've got to always count data how do
you normalize it and
we had a great talk a great talk by
David earlier about exactly this kind of
question
it's very complicated when you have
replicates of jellyfish that are starved
and fed like do you combine them all
together to normalize the data or do you
do them one at a time question a simple
question which normalization procedure
do you use same with the Single Cell
isoform stuff do you do
the smart technology separately from the
10x yeah maybe the technology looks
different we had a lot of debates about
that similarly we realized that we were
very confused about Dimension reduction
procedures like the reason people care
about the you know normalizing their
data is because for steps like PCA you
don't want to have a lot more variance
in your highly expressed genes because
then your whole PC is just dominated by
them and so
um so it's one thing as you know a
statistician to think about these
questions it's another thing to
implement them as a computer scientist
in 38 billion reads and it's the third
thing as a biologist who really care
about the answer and I learned all those
lessons the hard way in these projects
well are there other questions as well
about how to use the replicas and how to
elucidate differentiation trajectories
and these are interesting questions and
for each of them we had a sort of sub
question that made us uncomfortable
should you even normalize data why are
we actually applying Dimension reduction
and is it really necessary
um
how should experiment you know
replicants be actually collect all these
things so I won't talk about all this
today
um I thought actually a long time about
what you know what to talk about here
and and I apologize Roderick for my late
um abstract submission but part of the
reason was I wanted to you know I really
debated which of us to talk about today
and I thought the second one would be
interesting but I'm going to talk about
the first thing okay so that's that's
what I'm going to do so I'm ready to go
into part two and talking about
exploratory data analysis very briefly I
think it's interesting you know I
learned and I was in Chain of Statistics
at all I'm not a statistician I sort of
studied math but coming to Berkeley uh
you know many years ago as a postdoc
first I was really transformative for me
because Berkeley has the stats
Department which many schools don't have
and here I learned one of the first
things I learned from friends and
colleagues here someone from here today
is about exploratory data analysis and
there's a great book about it by John
tukey and
um you know this I mean I think it's
fair to say that the Berkeley statistics
tradition which is not the same as all
the other statistics Traditions involves
really look doing exploratory data
analysis before you really start to like
understand your data and I learned that
from the statisticians here
um but the interesting thing is
exploratory data analysis is not really
about you know just making plots with
your data it's I think how some people
use it today but it's about really and
this is you know the way Tuki thought
about it was the purpose of it is in
part to assess your assumptions and to
select your appropriate tools and and I
think that's important to keep in mind
and this was another Point turkey made
as you know not to generate and test
hypotheses on the same data and we heard
this we're double dipping today many
times it's very interesting issue and
it's kind of that issue
so the the the plot I learned like I
literally learned this in 2001 the first
thing you do with your data is you make
mean variance plots and I was happy to
see some of them today and this is from
a paper that I even think was referenced
earlier by David if I'm not mistaken
um it's from Wolfgang grouper and uh
and they looked at you know different
data sets we might focus on the bottom
row here these are cell lines
um and if you look at single cell and AC
data what's also true for both on your
seek it's true for most count data
actually
um you know by there's Randomness in the
sampling and
that leads to uh a poisson relationship
it's called because the poisson is a
good
approximation to the multinomial
distribution and so you kind of expect
to see this line Y equals X but real
data sets are sort of over dispersed or
um
uh super linear
and typically what's done is a quadratic
is for to them because that is uh the
variance relationship you expect from a
negative binomial
so this is something that everybody does
in single cell rna-seq is sort of
understand this fact
and in the negative binomial
distribution which I won't say much
about but it has the property that it's
variance is quadratic in the mean and so
you can estimate this parameter feed
which is how much over dispersion you
have and why do people do this because
if you didn't worry about this issue and
you just stick your data like into some
procedure like PCA which is what a lot
of people do then right if you if the
genes that are very uh you know highly
expressed they're going to dominate the
whole analysis basically right so so
that's why and there's a procedure
called variant stabilization it's
classic his goal is to remove this
relationship and that's what I want to
talk about briefly so one thing I'll say
and it's important is that the negative
binomial actually makes sense
mechanistically from a statistical point
of view because
while the poisson arises from random
sampling you know you reach into the jar
and you pull out different rnas
um if you assume that the rate parameter
of the poisson is gamma distributed then
you're really looking at a mixture of
poissons then you get that's one way to
understand what the negative binomial
distributions so there's some
combinatorial interpretations but this
one is statistically relevant in this
example because you might think okay
you know maybe different cell types have
a slightly different sampling rate or
genes of different type that rate
variation in the poisson is what leads
to the over dispersion and I think
what's people that's what people imagine
and and you know uh we even heard it
today several times
there's the technical variation that
people usually think about the actual
sampling sometimes people talk about
biological variation is what you might
see in different replicates biological
replicates that's you know sort of the
excess stuff
or I just want to say one last thing
about the classical statistics and then
I'll move on is that there's a
literature on this one it's 1930s
actually but in 1948 and sperm wrote a
sort of important paper on this and he
showed that using this thing called the
Delta method which is basically Taylor
series expansion you can derive the
transformation of your data that
stabilizes the variance that makes it so
that the highly expressed genes have
similar variance to the lower
expressions and this is you know this
transformation has some nice properties
like I mean you could just set all the
variances equal all right um that's
simple but this transformation is
monotonic and has some nice properties
and that's why people use it and in
particular
an approximation to the sort of thing
you get out these days you can get this
in one line in Mathematica is the log
transform and that's why people log
their data right because it is actually
the right transformation for negative
binomial distributed but what in one
Insight that comes from reading nscom in
1948 is that the pseudo count which
usually is set to one because that's
what's implemented in Python and R in
most packages corresponds to an
assumption about the over dispersion
actually the more or less over dispersed
your debt is you would actually change
the pseudo count and if you really want
to actually test log on your data you
should actually learn that you know you
should make this plot
um uh sorry I should say you should make
one of these plots and fit the quadratic
and actually put the right thing and at
least one should do that most people
don't do that but it turns out that one
yeah it's pretty close to what most data
looks like although there's High
variability
anyway that's sort of uh most of my part
two that's why people log transform
their data all right
so we really like started to look at
this you know I said we had some
anxieties over the analysis we were
doing
and one of the things we did is we
reversed in genetic Surat because this
is a program that almost everybody uses
for their data in fact today I think
there were several Surat images
it turns out that you know
log is not actually what people mostly
do in their analysis sometimes it is
I'm not going to go through detail in
this thing but there's a Surat object
if you just want to like we just want to
understand like what happens when you
run the standard software on your data
and it's not documented exactly anywhere
so we read the source code and Mr Rod
object there's three so-called slots
like the program holds three matrices in
memory at once
and there's different procedures you can
apply to these slots like they can be
the raw counts you can put in this
scale.data can be the log data or it can
be some other transformation there's
several options one of the recommended
ones by the authors of Surat is a thing
called SC transform which is some method
to compute Pearson residuals and then
you know these different slots get used
in different functions I don't know if
you can read this but typically people
do PCA and that uses one slot and then
you have different slots being used when
you do differential analysis and it's
it's very very complicated all right so
the main point was that we started to
wonder whether we knew anything really
about what Transformations the right one
or anybody had assisted so we decided to
look at it and we wrote a pre-print it
just came out early this year
um so first thing I'll say
and I'll get on to part three we looked
at you know how I wouldn't I wouldn't
use the word well but how effectively
these map how effective the methods are
at actually stabilizing events there's
another issue which is different cells
are sequenced to different depth and we
looked at you know whether the depth is
being you know made uniform because
that's one of the goals of these methods
and um we also looked at whether the
Transformations were monotonic or not
because that is
yeah I implicitly assumed in some
Downstream analysis and we we ended up
so this is just one data set it's the
cell line I showed you earlier we looked
at nine methods just the raw counts this
is just the normalization of the depth
alone this is
the log transformation what's often done
is a combination of those first you
normalize the depth and then you log the
data that's very standard in almost all
workflows uh this is the SC transform
this is another common option
um so I I don't have time to go through
all of it but one thing I wanted to say
is that getting this done in 520 data
sets was both very difficult
and very informative usually people look
at one or two data sets maybe three
um there's a wide this is just to show
you on these three measures or whatever
they are there's like a very wide range
for a given method on how effective it
is for example in the top when it's
stabilizing the variance
um
and uh and yeah and so we saw that you
know this is very very data set specific
on what method you should use and uh and
we we learned a lot from this and it's
in our preprint and I won't say more
about it now I do want to say that in
order to do this analysis of just
looking at these data sets and seeing
even just what the normalizations do
required us to have access to lots of
data and we went looking for it in
various human cell atlases and we
couldn't get the we needed the raw data
because we wanted to normalize all the
counts themselves and this is a very
nice paper from last year it's by
several authors Michael Hoffman I think
Stephanie Hicks was mentioned earlier as
an author here where they set out like
you know reproducibility standards they
gave bronze silver and gold that's their
like metric and so assessing these
various atlices by these metrics as you
can see you sort of have silver and
bronze but we couldn't find anywhere
with all the data all the methods that
made it easy so
I want to talk about it today because
I'm only ready for part three but we
created a cell Atlas framework that is
reproducible and and these 526 data sets
which we you can uh we have not
published this yet but we will soon
allow anyone to Benchmark any of the
methods that they have would like
um in a uniform way on uniform process
data that we didn't generate but that we
have cohesively reanalyzed uh via a very
complicated framework that was developed
by my student angelsagi
um which is sort of a living Atlas
um you can insert new data sets we have
an automated GitHub processing framework
where data comes in it gets processed
automatically it gets added to our Atlas
um anyway it's what allowed us to do
this
all right so with that in hand having a
look at all these normalization methods
having all this data in our hands we
finally asked the question Okay so
what should we actually do with our data
and I think there was a cool slide
showing there's a thousand uh
tools are out now for a single cell
there's among those there's probably a
few dozen normalization tools
um we wondered like does log suffice and
if not log like what should we actually
use
um and we spend a lot of time thinking
about this and
one of the insights that came from
another student of mine gennaragorn is
that actually
the maybe there's something missed by
many people which is that the negative
binomial is sort of in and of itself
uh sort of interesting to think about uh
and as a first point like why do we
normalize at all
um and his inside was the following so
on the right hand side here I've sort of
summarized in one sentence what the
current mindset is in genomics about
single cell and for that matter most
count data is that there's technical
variation and maybe some excess
variation due to technology or
maybe you know biology somehow that that
the data is ends up being negative
binomial and you should basically model
this distribution or even zero inflated
or something a little bit even tweaked
so that you don't have these effects
between mean and various
there's an entirely different literature
which is quite foreign in genomics not
entirely but mostly which comes from
physics which has to do with modeling
transcription mechanistically and it
turns out I'll show you very briefly
the the current popular model in that
field usually yields a negative binomial
distribution on the counts
purely from biological mechanistic
considerations with that in regard to
the actual sampling that happens in the
actual experiments we do with all the
cdnas and umis you've heard it and all
that
well so so that's sort of interesting
and the question is well why is that and
what to do about it
I can tell you just in two slides where
this comes from so
in biology starting in the 1950s with
Manoa and Jacob and others people
started to write down you know chemical
reaction Network models for
transcription and they had very simple
ordinary differential equations like
this with a rate of transcription is
some constant with some degradation
and these models I point out in this
footnote here I sort of persisted
actually for you know 50 years because
60 years because
at that time it was very difficult to
measure anything you know you didn't
have single cell or any secrets so you
had like so an idea about you know this
is a very very very very basic model for
transcription but this model
is first of all continuous you know you
know molecules are discrete and we know
that there actually might be very few
molecules of some Gene in the cell more
importantly there's no stochasticity in
in this kind of model uh you know you
can solve for the model but there's no
idea of stochasticity in the
transcription or in the splicing you
know people later extended this to
include splicing you know you can make
instead of you know you start with from
your DNA making unspliced RNN and then
you have another you know uh
differential equation that's coupled to
this one where
the transcripts got spliced and then
those make protein but but even so
there's no stochasticity and so
to ameliorate that issue and this is
about 20 years old work not not for me
um but but it's sort of classic now in
in systems biology is what's called a
chemical Master equation or and this
model is very simple actually it looks
like this and I've shown the most simple
instantiation of it where you have
generation of molecules by some red can
degradation by Red Lambda but this is
now a discrete model
imagine sort of a rope with knots and
time is continuous and at every instant
you either hop up and make a new
molecule or you lose a molecule okay so
this is and and the rate at which you
hop up or down that that there's some
you know poisson process with with the
rate for transcription and degradation
and that model if you just work it out
you can solve it and it's steady state
distribution is the poisson distribution
all right so if you believe that there's
stochasticity in when molecules actually
get transcribed you end up with the
poisson distribution
um most of these kind of models that
would be relevant for biology where you
have splicing and proteins and whatnot
are not tractable in this way they end
up with you know this complicated
generating functions you have to solve
but people simulate these things with
something called the gillespialidine
which is very classic
so the model that's favored right now is
called the telegraph model or the bursty
transcription model
in this model it's the same as what I
showed before
you have you know uh you you J you know
you have some red for each gene eye it's
different for each Genet which you
generate
you know molecules and then they degrade
except that you have this Telegraph part
where you're either on or off imagine I
mean this comes from the idea of
transcription factors are necessary to
initiate transcription so you know you
have if the transcription factor is
sitting there okay you can start
generating molecules but if it goes off
you don't make anything and now there's
a new parameter which is or you know the
the rate or two parameters the rate at
which you switch off and switch on
this model is obviously too simplistic
you need to model splicing there's lots
of other stuff degradation rates are
going to depend on the Gene maybe your
genes interact but this is the zeroth
order model in the field and
the nice thing about this particular
model is two things first it has it
didn't just come about from thought
experiments it came about from fish
experiments from fluorescent into
urbanization where you can do one single
Gene in a Cell so yeah single cell but
not in the genomic sense
and that's what the data actually looked
like and then second thing is in this
particular model you can also actually
solve for the steady state distribution
and it's it's a long calculation I won't
bore you with it
um and you get out the negative binomial
in the in the limit and it's really
interesting uh you know so here you know
you you sort of don't try if you're an
off stick nothing happens when you go on
you make a bunch of stuff then you're
off again then you're on and so it's
called the bursty transcription model
and I won't I won't bore you with like
all the details of the duration or and
it's very interesting actually to look
at all the limiting cases of this but
you get out the negative binomial very
naturally from purely mechanistic
considerations
so there's actually an interesting thing
going on here which is that
and systems biology people have shown if
you take a class in that of Caltech for
example it's taught by my physics
colleagues
um Rob Phillips and Michael ellowitz
they explained that you know always
you'll get Negative binomial count
distributions if you go to genomics
conference or take a genomics class
you're taught that the data is negative
binomial and the log transform is the
right one to normalize the data so here
you have everyone trying to remove the
noise but the noise maybe is the biology
and by that I mean the mechanistic
biology so it seems that there's a sort
of problem here right like what should
actually be doing and are you maybe
throwing you know the biology out with
the noise
so the last slide I'll show and I think
I have three or four minutes and it'll
take a little moment to explain is from
another preprint by Gennady on the
method we call Mano uh named after
um manot
um and
so we actually have implemented a model
on the mechanistic model the telegraph
bursting model and actually several
others that include sampling rates from
the cdnas this that is the poisson noise
that you usually see but where we can
tell apart what's biological in a sense
mechanistic biological and Technical and
that's what's shown on the y-axis here
um
where this is a fraction of biological
variance we compared that to this is the
log with depth normalization but we've
done many others as well we're here on
the y-axis you look at what's the
fraction of biological variance given by
the normalization now how can you do
that well when you normalize your data
with one of the standard methods you
know you decrease the variance but the
events doesn't all become equal and so
you can ask how much Vance was left on
the table and you can say okay that
amount
that's what's the biology right so
that's about and that's how we did this
calculation here now for the x-axis we
have a lower band we computed we don't
we it's very hard for us to know in real
in reality what's biological and what's
technical but we could compute a lower
band and the way we did that is we took
data where there are different cell
types
and we averaged gene expression across
all the cells in one cell type so now we
actually have a very good estimate of
the expression there because we have
many many cells per cell type and
because they're acid in one experiment
so there are no artifacts between data
sets and we look at the variance of the
gene between cell types which we assume
at that point
is not due to sampling because we've
done so much averaging but it's due to
actual biology
and what you can see here is that with
standard normalizations and this is true
not just for log with depth minimization
but for every method we've tried there
is a massive underprediction of the
actual amount of biology that's in the
data because basically
you've assumed that all the events
you're seeing should be removed by and
then you're stabilizing the events it's
almost a topology
in our method we are essentially
reducing much less variability
um maybe not enough but we don't know so
that's we're not done but that's that's
where we stand now and I should say that
you know it's it's interesting you know
um
I haven't explained exactly how this
model works and how we got these
estimates but that it actually is very
interesting and it requires using
spliced and unspliced data and and and
uh it requires quite a lot of work which
I don't have time to talk about
so the summarize to my last slide I
think mechanistic models of
transcription are helpful and possibly
necessary for actually distinguishing
the biological from technical variants
and single salary seek
it's very doable
um it turns out that the data you need
to do this is from what are called
spliced and unspliced matrices
these were first considered in the
context of RNA velocity which is a
interesting technique that people use
um in fact I'm trying to understand Rd
velocity led us also in part to the
development of Manoa I'll just point to
the preprint we've written it's a long
treatment but it it analyzes the
foundations of the Sony velocity it's
interesting because
this framework in which you get arrows
on your cells and try to figure out
where they're going
is
somehow like intrinsically requires a
mechanistic model you're trying to say
you know this cell is changing into that
cell it's the same with pseudo time if
you know you know someone I'm not going
to talk about it but when you try to
order cells and say the differentiating
ones trajectory you're making
mechanistic claims and so you cannot
escape the mechanism in this context
um you know you don't need mechanism
necessarily if you're just going to like
build an atlas although I think you do
but for these
time applications where you sort cells
or try to figure out the velocity you
just can't escape it and so so that's
what we wrote about there
this framework we built which we should
be able to pre-print I think in a month
or two
um hopefully you'll find it useful if
you're working in single cell rnac
because we have a very uniformly
processed data set which can be
reprocessed by you and for free and so
it's completely accessible with all the
reads available and so forth and so on
and I'll just end with this point I
didn't get to talking about umaps today
but I've written a little bit about them
recently and I think that's an
interesting thing to talk about and I
think that there's a lot of interesting
discussion to be had and work to be done
in general about exploratory data
analysis in this domain not just for the
application of normalization so I'll end
with that and thanks again to everybody
thank you
foreign
I just have a question regarding this
last part the estimation of biological
variance so does this Goring paper
provide a package for estimating
biological variance from data yes it
does there's a package called Mono it's
written in Python and it uh yes it will
utilize the spliced and unspliced
matrices in order to estimate uh these
parameters not just the technical events
but also the degradation I mean there's
three free parameters it turns out you
can estimate
um just two things I'll say about it is
that these are not self-specific
estimates in order to get these
estimates we have to look at many cells
I see and um the second is is that it's
quite computational intensive actually
process uh but yes it's developed for
for use as a general python package I
see does it work for 10x data as well
yes absolutely
um and again it doesn't work for every
Gene also because you need splicing
unsplice reads but it was developed
precisely for 10x data which facilitates
getting the unspliced reads by virtue of
having you know the you know so 10x has
these poly T captures they're supposed
to capture the polyadenylated
transcripts but they end up also
capturing unspliced reads that happen to
have poly a tracks and that's why we can
do this I see thank you
questions
[Applause]